There are two more features I wanted to mention on inputs.
The required attribute and the place holder attribute. Required just let's
me say, this field is required before you can submit the
form. So, for example, if I want to make sure that
my lemur afficianados enter a telephone number, I can do that
right on the input. Now, if I try to go into
this field, and let's say I don't want to give a telephone
number, so I just skip it And I try to submit
the form. It tells me that I have to fill that field
out. The other feature, is the placeholder text. You may want to give
hints to your users. In some fields, they go away when they start
typing. You can do that pretty easily by just setting a placeholder attribute.
And now you can tell I get placeholder text
in that field. But once I start typing something,
it goes away. None of this removes the need
for server side validation of course, but it does
make it easier users not to accidentally submit something
that's not valid, and it doesn't require any JavaScript
on your page to do that or to provide
place holder text that get's out of the user's way.